[Musica]
[Applauso]
gli è mai stato chiesto da bambini cosa
vuoi fare da grande ammessi e ho
cambiato mestiere quasi ogni anno fino a
quando all'età di nove anni la mia foto
non fu messa su un album delle figurine
cosicché risposi con certezza voglio
fare la pallavolista in realtà anche se
la pallavolo mi ha accompagnato per
parecchi anni anche con questo mestiere
mi sbagliavo
il nome della squadra in cui giocavo
però le byte era un acronimo seal di le
bimbe terribili ma se ci pensate è anche
un'unità di misura informatica della
capacità di memoria di un computer
quindi ha fatto un po da segno
premonitore diciamo del mio futuro da
ingegnere in realtà cosa fare da grande
e una scelta che ho maturato nel corso
degli anni dopo il liceo scientifico
scelsi di proseguire gli studi di
ingegneria civile da una parte mi
piaceva le discipline scientifiche
avevo sempre un libro in mano e poi mi
piaceva anche l'idea di trovare una
soluzione concreta problemi reali e
dall'altra ingegneria civile offriva
molte prospettive nel mercato del lavoro
ed è così che scelsi quella strada e
proprio durante la preparazione della
tesi di laurea che ci fu la svolta
la mia tesi riguardava allo studio di
perdite idriche in particolari tipi di
tubazioni e l'idea di studiare l'acqua
che è una risorsa preziosa per il
pianeta combinandosi aspetti teorici si
aspetti più pratici mi entusiasmò poi il
mio relatore mi parlò addirittura della
possibilità di presentare i miei
risultati di tesi ancora prima di
laurearmi ad un congresso internazionale
in sudafrica immaginate l'emozione il
primo viaggio da sola molto lontano da
casa ma anche la prima presentazione
inglese di fronte a un pubblico esperto
di esperti accademici e però fu
bellissimo e b la possibilità di
presentare i miei risultati le mie idee
a persone di diversa formazione di
diversa cultura nazione e così che
capire quella era la strada giusta e
proseguì gli studi dopo la laurea non
gli studi di magia come potreste
immaginare guardando questo abito che
indossavo di cerimonia studi di
dottorato che appunto completa e
disputando nella tesi nel 2014 e poi
dopo una serie di contratti sia
all'estero che in italia
divenire circatrice nel 2019 presso
l'università di pavia ma ora la domanda
è cosa serve per fare il ricercatore e
voglio rispondere a questa domanda
facendo un parallelismo forse ne avete
sentito parlare addirittura visto fin
d'animazione l'era glaciale
in questo film c'è un buffo scoiattolino
di nome scrat lui ama le ghiande e ha
una missione quella di
raccogliere una ghianda e adesso non
voglio offendere i miei colleghi
ricercatori se li paragono a uno
scoiattolo è un esempio molto semplice e
chiaro
come scrat anche il ricercatore ha una
missione quella di dare un contributo
alla scienza alla scienza può essere
piccolo grande che sia ma per compiere
un progresso per l'umanità
pensate a questo contributo può essere
ad esempio un nuovo metodo sperimentale
una nuova teoria nuovo farmaco una nuova
tecnologia un modello matematico ma
quello che conta è che per compiere
questa missione
occorrono tre ingredienti chiave e
questi c'è l'insegna appunto il nostro
amico scrat
primo ingrediente la curiosità il
pensate scrat e uno scoiattolino curioso
lui cerca ovunque annusa ovunque pur di
trovare la sua ghianda e così come scrat
anche per il ricercatore la curiosità è
vitale ad esempio galileo ci racconta
nel saggiatore una favola in questa
favola c'è un uomo che si molto
intelligente ma soprattutto molto
curioso e lui voglia conoscere l'origine
dei suoni pensava infatti che i suoni
avessero origine solo dagli uccelli e in
realtà scopre durante questa indagine
che i suoni hanno origine anche da dalle
cicale dai mosconi addirittura dalle
porte quindi in questa favola ci insegna
che la conoscenza inesauribile e quindi
il ricercatore deve sempre guardare il
mondo circostante con una mente aperta
creativa e soprattutto curiosa però
essendo instabili deve essere anche in
grado di mettere sempre in discussione
quello che sa ed è appunto questa mente
aperta creativa curiosa che ha portato a
scoperte rivoluzionarie nel corso della
storia ad esempio sapete come sono stati
scoperti i raggi ics
per caso ad esempio c'era appunto noto
novembre del 1895 il fisico tedesco
röntgen era nel suo laboratorio
completamente al buio stava studiando
dei particolari tipi di fenomeni
luminosi in
particolari tipi di tubi e quello che
osservò un bagliore su uno schermo possa
distanza da questi tubi quindi
incuriosito da questo fenomeno decise di
approfondirlo addirittura a ruolo anche
la moglie nei suoi esperimenti e quello
che scoprirci questo i bagliori e non
dovuti o dei raggi invisibili che
appunto chiamo hicks per la misteriosa
origine e questi raggi e non in grado di
penetrare la carta in legno ma non il
piombo e soprattutto approfondendo e
sostituendo lo schermo con una lastra
fotografica fu in grado di eseguire la
prima radiografia della mano della
moglie nella storia e questo gli valse
anche il primo premio nobel per la
fisica del 1901 quindi capite come
ricercatore deve essere curioso quindi
cercare e più cerca più trova ciò che
gli piace quindi secondo ingrediente
chiave di un ricercatore la passione
pensiamo sempre il nostro amico scrat
lui ama le ghiande ed è proprio l'amore
per le ghiande che lo spinge a cercare
continuamente e così la passione vitale
per un ricercatore e lo spinge il suo
motore quotidiano quindi ricollegandoci
appunto leonardo da vinci lui aveva
questa passione per il volo e questa
passione lo spinse ad applicare le sue
conoscenze per la prima volta pur di
mettere le ali all'uovo e arrivò
addirittura a progettare il primo
paracadute nella storia che fu
addirittura testato negli anni 2000 da
un inglese nicholas che si lanciò 3000
metri di altezza in sudafrica e per
fortuna ebbe successo
e quindi come leonardo anch'io sono un
ricercatore quindi ho la mia passione e
questa passione
non sono i fiori anche se in realtà mi
piacciono tanto i fiori ma sono i
materiali sono una componente
fondamentale della nostra vita
quotidiana
ma cosa hanno a che fare i fiori con i
materiali
beh se ci pensate in questo esempio
vedete uno dei tanti grandiosi esempi di
meccanismo di funzionamento presenti in
natura dei fiori che si aprono e si
chiudono passando dal giorno alla notte
e ora pensate ai materiali la scienza
l'ingegneria e la tecnologia dei
materiali è progredito talmente tanto
che noi possiamo realizzare dei
materiali su misura in base alle nostre
esigenze e ad esempio ci sono materiali
cosiddetti intelligenti sia materiali
che rispondono a stimoli esterni
modificando le loro proprietà come lo
vedete in questo video sono un materiale
che risponde un semplice stimolo ottico
generato da una luce led che appunto si
apre e si chiude con un fiore e quindi
quello che io faccio appunto sviluppare
modelli teorici matematici spesso
integrati anche i codici di calcolo per
capire
la relazione tra la struttura del
materiale
il processo di fabbricazione di
manifattura e le proprietà finali e
quindi puoi sfruttare questa
comprensione per
risolvere problemi pensate ad esempio al
futuro acceleratore di particelle del
cern a ginevra è un ambiente altamente
radioattivo la presenza dell'uomo è
molto pericolosa per attività ad esempio
di manutenzione ed installazione dei
vari dispositivi connessi in quindi la
possibilità di utilizzare materiali
intelligenti che sono controllabili da
remoto tra noli tramite stimoli esterni
è di fondamentale importanza per ridurre
la presenza dell'uomo in questi ambienti
e quindi capito e come anche comprendere
il comportamento di questi materiali per
poi ottimizzarne il loro uso è
importante è però il bello della ricerca
è che libertà libertà di ampliare i
propri orizzonti
dovete sapere che in realtà avevo mi
piaceva se dal liceo anche le scienze
mediche la biologia e quindi avevo anche
superato i test d'ingresso a medicina
ero stato a messa poi il mio spirito da
ingegneria prevalso nella scelta finale
ma dal ricerca mi permette anche di
ampliare argomenti in queste discipline
che sono ben lontani dalla mia
formazione originale di ingegnere civile
e quindi ad esempio io studio
l'applicazione dei materiali che sto
considerando per risolvere problematiche
anche in queste discipline
e quindi colleghiamoci
il ricercatore curioso cerco ovunque
trova la sua passione ma inevitabile
trovare difficoltà e in questo ci
colleghiamo all'ultimo il terzo ma anche
il più importante ingrediente che la
tenacia il
pensiamo chi non ha mai trovato dei
problemi di fronte a sé dei muri sia
nella vita che nel lavoro pensiamo
sempre a scrat lui uno scoiattolino lui
incontra tantissime avversità ma lui
procede imperterrito per la sua strada
lui anche con simpatica testardaggine
lui trova delle soluzioni eco sia nel
mondo della ricerca noi pensiamo ad
esempio il lavoro del ricercatore spesso
non ha orari
lavoriamo anche nel weekend la sera
durante le festività poi il i fondi sono
pochi sono limitati c'è molta
competizione spesso i test sperimentali
non vengono modelli matematici che non
colgono bene il problema il fenomeno
reale e poi la precarietà purtroppo non
aiuta
in tutto questo e mettetevi ora anche
nei panni di un ricercatore donna i
problemi ovviamente sono ancora maggiori
quindi la possibilità io stesso ero
chiamata la ragazza con la valigia si
viaggia molto nel mondo della ricerca e
appunto per il numero di ore che passavo
su un aereo o su una macchina e poi ci
sono ovviamente discipline che
richiedono anche presenze periodiche o
costanti in laboratorio e questo
ovviamente fa sì che ci siano anche
stereotipi legati al contesto culturale
c'è un test disegna uno scienziato che
viene proposto ai bambini e le bambine
per capirne la loro visione dello
scienziato della scienziata questo
stesso è stato
c'è stato uno studio pubblicato nel 2018
dal miller autore che hanno analizzato
più di 20 mila test eseguiti tra gli
stati uniti e il canada su 20.000
appunto disegni e quello che è emerso è
che solamente il 28 per cento considera
la possibilità di uno scienziato donna e
questo ovviamente ha influenza anche sul
numero di donne nella ricerca
specialmente nel campo dove lavoro io
quindi i campi stem quelli di scienze
tecnologia ingegneria e matematica
e se questo era chiaro ad esempio nel
1911 dove le donne erano
dove marie curie era l'unica donna
presente al primo congresso solvay a
bruxelles ora i dati purtroppo sono
ancora preoccupanti ve lo capiamo ad
esempio guardando confrontando punti
dati forniti a marzo 2021 dal nostro
ministero dell'istruzione
confrontano la carriera accademica nelle
aree sam tra uomini e donne è quello il
divario per le più alte cariche
accademiche è notevole passiamo dalle 21
per cento di donne al 79 per cento di
uomini come professori ordinari in
questo ambito nel 2019 in particolare e
questo ci insegna che qualcosa deve
essere fatto ma non solo per la ricerca
ma anche per le donne nella ricerca e
quindi come fare a saltare questo muro
voglio rispondere con questa frase
nostra grande scienziata rita levi
montalcini le difficoltà della vita sono
una potenzialità della vita in cui
occorre imparare dagli errori dal
fallimento e farne tesoro e soprattutto
occorre lavorare con tenacia e quindi
mettersi sempre in gioco e credere
fortemente in se stessi anche nelle
proprie idee quindi riassumendo la
nostra domanda iniziale era cosa serve
per fare il ricercatore allora fare il
ricercatore una scelta avete capito
coraggiosa sia per uomini che per donne
comporta dei sacrifici
ma pensate dare un contributo
comunque la scelta alla scienza
l'umanità è di fondamentale importanza
galan che molti situazioni e quindi però
non è sufficiente avere intelligenza
metodo scientifico anche fortuna quella
serve sempre ma occorre lavorare sodo
con curiosità passione e tenacia e
aggiungo anche un altro ingrediente che
invece mi ha insegnato la la pallavolo
che il gioco di squadra
occorre appunto
lavorare insieme i problemi ci sono e
sono altamente multidisciplinari quindi
imparare dal passato dalle proprie
figure di riferimento sia che siano
allenatori docenti di riferimento
compagni di squadra o colleghi grazie a
tutti per l'attenzione
[Applauso]